good morning Millennials good morning
everyone welcome to the morning toast
today is Thursday July 26 let me check I
want to say yes we got it right
September I'm like off completely except
for the toast but and camp toast
September is a nice time to be awesome
hammers a great time of year honestly
like you got married in September and
like if I could do things differently I
would be getting married in the fall I
think September is the best months to
get married let me tell you why because
everyone thinks like Megan June is like
wedding time so it's on peak
everything's more expensive and harder
to bug and that's what like this climate
change like the weather is just so unfit
it's so unpredictable it's more likely
to rain in April showers like it's more
likely bring May flowers but the May
flowers still required they're delayed
yeah big imagine you thought like you
wanted a summer wedding weekend you're
having an outdoor wedding
la-dee-da and so you get married in the
middle of July last weekend yeah
hurricane hurricane but July is in a hot
wedding month June and May are and I
just want to say like as a person who's
been to many a wedding all time of year
inside outside there's nothing I hate
more than an outdoor wedding in the
summer and like I don't know why that's
like a popular thing it's miserable like
I spend the whole day getting ready and
then I get to the reception and I hit my
makeup it's down to my toes and like you
can't plan your wedding date around
whether good or bad you can't hope for a
summer wedding said that you were you're
planning on a good day because you know
what you're gonna get rain and you know
you can't let a winter storm or the
thought of a winter storm stop you from
having a winter wedding you should just
I disagree I just there's no predicting
the weather and so if you start to let
it factor into your plans you're just
getting anxiety about stuff that you
can't control you know what I'm getting
around in the winter if the big storm of
2019 decides to follow my wedding
weekend meant to be less people holding
their cheaper saw ready pay for it but
whatever yeah and then you know like Sam
and Deena by the way speaking of Dana
tonight we are filming our fifth patreon
episode of the month with Deena aka Judy
Brown I would posting a master post in
the toast after dark for all the bar
questions for her about her about me
maybe she's like been my closest friend
since college and she's just a wealth of
knowledge and we'll talk about it on the
podcast but if you wanted to get to know
her
subscribe to the page on patreon.com
slash morning toast but Sam and Dana
they didn't know each other back in the
day they had the same bat mitzvah date
with in like 2007 no fun and it was the
blizzard of January 2007 and no one
could go to either of their bat mitzvahs
but they knew about each other's but my
sisters are competing I remember someone
at the same games right state area we
would devour a circuit ER Mitzvah let's
say show Friday night and totally but
back to September I wanted to ask your
advice on something because I got I've
so much traveling like work and personal
like in autism pleasure this is a
pleasure next week I'm going to Bogota
Colombia for a wedding and then I'm like
Philly Raleigh Alabama Buffalo literally
I just don't stop in August okay what
did you want to ask me so I have this
wedding in Israel September 2nd Labor
Day weekend right before camp Joe's okay
and like I was definitely putting on
going the whole time and then when I
booked all these shows I'm like it might
have to take a backseat
but then I've just been like talking
like to people that I know and like
literally everyone I know from different
circles there's another wedding in
Israel that that weekend so like all my
friends are gonna go from both sides and
then like random like Eric's coming to
Israel that week so like literally
everyone's gonna go it's just gonna be
so hard for me like just with the travel
missing so much toast and then I get
home in two days later we go to campus
like I just I'm so on the fence oh and
flights we couldn't be more expensive
should I go oh I thought you were gonna
say will you come and we'll do the
toaster misra
oh sure but like oh you know what like I
was planning on no but like this week I
literally found out that everyone's
going that we think and by the way there
was a weekend last summer where everyone
went to Israel I'm like I was like I
wasn't even busy but I was like man I
want to go and I like had the biggest of
regret FOMO of my life here's the thing
you should go and I'm gonna tell you why
first of all it sounds amazing
regardless of like any other detail
second of all like you're the youngest
you're getting into the best shape of
your life that you're ever gonna be in a
program now can't wait to see where
you're they're so true take it around
town John I mean literally lucky though
the flights are so expensive because
it's like it's like a holiday together
you're not working all August for
nothing like that you know I've been
treating myself so much because you know
this ring that I have I get so many
compliments on it looks like a it's a
Jewish star it's fake as [ __ ] it turns
my finger green I bought it like on the
street in Israel
50 shekel which is like $20 and I just
really love it I wear it every day I
think it's so special and I've been
really wanting to like contact did you
alert it's like having it made real for
me and I just haven't been in like a
good panel spot my credit went down 37
points you need to get yourself a dirty
jeans tour gift right so is that it
this ring might be it and I contacted
Ben thriller yes I do tucking it because
I'm applying for apartments and I
checked it like two weeks ago Mona's
that's seven oh one out of eight hundred
like that's a really good how did you go
down do you just like forget to pay your
credit card or something no so when you
like I'm I put my payments up to my
credit card our automatic every month
some in the middle of the month you have
a kind of a high bill but I'm not even
close to my limit actually I'm like 75%
to my limit but I'm not late just like
the fact that I have a balance I pay it
every month I have like maybe once you
pay it then you'll check your balance
and yes it but it takes a while to like
update that's so weird and it's just so
annoying like I didn't if I was late I
understand my credit going down but like
I have a credit limit and I'm using it
and then my credit goes down credit is
so unfair I didn't want to check it it
fluctuates every time you check out so I
like can't stop checking it step teching
it it's [ __ ] credit 6:15 pickles and
getting on the scale like yeah it's just
not real wait stop checking it but no
it's really like it's so unfair
okay well I think we need to type in a
few things you're getting the ring and
I'm going to zero and you're going to
insert but that's like a lot that's like
let's look at all my earnings like from
like all the fee like well you don't
have to fly first class are you talking
first class well here's the thing
that's such an issue you know you have
so many friends who are going to Israel
like no one can give you a ride totally
I mean it's oh here I love using this
show as a platform does anyone have a
plane that they want to lend me or
they're already using to go to Israel
around Labor Day weekend your and your
dates are flexible very I'm super
flexible my last show of the summer is
August 24th I believe in New Jersey so
that's easy that's easy-peasy and then
yeah do it
Yolo sister yeah I'm gonna do it well
that's crazy I you're gonna tell that
definitely affects my Liberty plans cuz
thinking about going to like Montauk but
what's the point what do you mean what's
the point
like if steams aren't there oh right
yeah you know totally anyways TV
today what were we just talking about
before that wedding weddings whether we
were say we can't believe in Vegas you
remember the 21st night of September
moving I put in an application last
night and my credits low and I'm like so
upset that I mean I paid my credit card
bill last night and it posted this
morning so like how long till it
reflects my credit credit Carmen does
not affect your credit score no matter
how many times you check it no there's a
reason why they have all those
commercials
I don't understand free services how do
you have commercials um if you're a free
service yeah yeah kind of how does
Credit Karma make money cuz it's free
well like their website has
advertisements on it so that makes a
little bit money also I think they like
partner and like promote credit cards we
should that's tthe style he's one of the
goals is your TP oh my god but I'm not
gonna be here but I have so many
questions
believe them or maybe like he can guest
one time one time yeah doesn't leave a
lot of opportunity for guesting no it's
it's just when I had Darren on I did it
both I'm like let's I'm like don't even
talk to me about yourself for the first
30 minutes and then we're gonna dive
into all things Darren when I had Steven
on I had to get like a first five
minutes like what happened to some Rose
Fast Five
show us the receipts did I show you that
email 17 inches from Kyle those are the
best episodes where like the person is
both and I feel like we could have two
PG actually opposed do you think you
both
we could have T PG on like 10 times and
we'd still be learning more about him
like every time I hang out with him I
learn more about him he's so there's so
many sides to him like he has the
businessman side which fan he's so smart
like he needs to he's like if we let him
run our business he'd make us
millionaires like he's a genius okay and
then there's like what people don't know
about him he's like the most amazing
like just fun gay like just happy like
he loves Celine Dion he goes to see
Celine Dion every time he's in Vegas and
met her he like loves Demi like he's
just like people don't know that side of
him they know like the business side but
he has this like look literally one
night like two months ago we stayed in
his apartment and watch videos on
YouTube of like people singing like on
his TV till like 3:00 in the morning
like that's just so him that's so TPG
yeah
also another co-host that I'm having
while you're gone is Caroline Lundy from
The Bachelor so she's gonna co-host with
me and guess so
best of both routes situation when I'm
in Philadelphia tickets available girl
no job no comm sorry I believe it sold
out but I actually think that the Early
Show on August 6 has a couple more
tickets and I know that my show in
Phoenix has 15 more tickets left if you
want to come gee I only started bi you
sold out ok are you ready for the fast I
swear I am forty divided by the hormone
toast no I'm not you're not how do you
prepare for something like this usually
I something of this caliber usually I
feel like there's just more to talk
about before we get into it well more to
say better so basically I'm not really
feeling great I've had the runs since
last night and I almost had the runs in
an uber it was a moment am I thinking
when you were texting us that like year
I was doing a play-by-play I'm like I'm
in the over and I'm gonna [ __ ] out you
know what I was thinking that like so
what if you did like really say you shot
your pants in an uber you're alone like
you'll get charged more so they'll take
a toll on your financials but like just
go home and clean yourself up like at
least a time in public you know right i
mean and i was wearing leggings like a
pair that i could live without you know
wasn't my good jeans
and they and they were definitely gonna
be dirty jeans but like i see what
you're saying like there's no
ramifications but it's just like first
of all the absolute shame in knowing
that i an adult woman [ __ ] my pants for
sure but it's not your fault like it's
clearly the restaurant that you went
also the cleanup would be just like
miserable yeah yeah you'd have to tip
heavily like there's nothing worse than
duty um there is nothing worse than duty
but it then it's like as a mom you clean
up to eat i steve-o's mom you clean up
duty all the time oh my god Theo threw
up last night looks so weird in his
crazy
he was definitely feeling your pain I
was we were about to fall asleep I'm
like literally drifting to sleep and I
hear this like choking sound and Ben
came home super drunk and I thought
maybe it was like him like you know how
they always say like if you sleep on
your back when you're drunk you could
die yeah I'm literally shot up at a bad
thought Ben was dying and he look wasn't
moving and it was Theo like my poor son
just like threw up what happened to him
like nothing that's terrible I know I
was hoping he would bring Theo today I
haven't seen him in so long I was going
to but like I'm wearing black jeans and
he gets dirt all over them and I usually
take field with me when I have nothing
to do after the show that way we can
like go to your apartment that we can
lounge but I am busy today I need a
manicure I the meat
oh my god my nails are so disgusting
like nothing makes you feel like less of
a woman
than having dirt in your fingernails I
mean that's aggress and they feel like
that's something you're supposed to age
out of in the kindergarten like you get
on from kindergarten to your nails like
no I'm like a full-grown adult and I get
so much dirt under right now I have to
get a manicure but I was opening all
these packages yesterday and I cut
myself in five different ways so if I go
and the alcohol like I will die yeah so
now I had to hear about your little cuts
yeah I'm like one is literally in my
finger and then the others here so I
just I'm wounded okay the worst paper
cut I ever got was from the aluminum top
of Pedialyte it gave me this deep it
that was before I knew that you could
take the media like cap turn it over and
then you get the tinfoil like it's super
that's a really neat trick that not a
lot of people know and I was just doing
with my hand and I sliced my finger it
was like the deepest paper cut ever I
felt it in my soul okay you ready yeah
okay okay so the first step wait oh I'm
sorry here the past five stories that
you need to know before you wake up and
take a bite out of your morning toast
you guys oh we need to get that sound
effect yeah like member on blackberries
before you could screenshot you got that
app called crunch crunch crunch crunch
and when do you want to screenshot you
would open the menu impress crunch and
then it would wow
and it made that sound that's what we
need for here the past five stories we
used to have the push ah I will get it
and the tote someone's already made it's
right and the audio file think we do
that yeah yeah okay cool first step is
developing story Demi Lovato we're just
gonna keep updating you on her recovery
uh-huh um so this is a two-parter first
of all
Demi Lovato's friends had narcan on hand
before her overdose that is the craziest
thing so crazy Demi Lovato and her
friends reportedly had narcan on hand
while partying before her overdose the
25 year olds pals were reportedly
prepared for things to go bad and had
brought narcan an emergency medicine
used to reverse the effects of some drug
overdoses with them on a binge er the
night before she was hospitalized
according to People magazine she and her
friends were on a binge er the entire
night an insider told the magazine they
keep narcan on hand for such situations
they were prepared for this the people
she has been hanging around lately
aren't her real friends they don't have
her best interests at heart she's pushed
her true friends away on Tuesday
emergency personnel was called to
Lovato's block at 11:22 a.m. los angeles
time and transported a 25 year old woman
to a nearby hospital shortly afterward
Demi Lovato so I had a lot of thoughts
about this
first of all these aren't her real
friends that she's been partying with
but they had like a little bit of you
know
wherewithal to know to bring the narcan
which by the narcan it's like an
industrial medical like I don't know
where did they get it I mean you know
Hollywood you can get like anything on
the black market like you can literally
get a penis like you can get whatever
you want I don't know where you get in
our camp but like it's not the craziest
thing but it's pretty crazy that you can
get in our camp like in your house and
there's like Demi like leopard it's just
like need better friends and I think
that they should be friends with us
that's funny that you said that I think
hm and yes we drink meat you know if
we're hanging around I mean we're not
gonna drink and we can that we have like
so much fighting so much and laughter
with sober alcohol sometimes and like I
just feel like we're also good people
and like I am just like a secret like
I'm a ball almost box of Secrets no
vault you know I'm not I don't lie so
like if you asked me if you tell me
something and tell me not to tell anyone
I will not tell anyone and I also feel
like I give really good advice yeah and
I feel like I'm at all and I'm a fun gal
so I'm literally the good stuff I'm like
a boring Sarah breaking trend I'm also
really fun for and also like we have the
best time just like watching movie like
we don't have to like get [ __ ] up and
we do get [ __ ] up but we don't have to
get [ __ ] up to have fun so I feel like
summer nice we're sober could definitely
have a good time with it so funny that
you say that cuz blurry when I was
having the runs this morning I was
thinking about what I'm gonna say an
hour Real Housewives of New York recap
and we'll get to that at the end of
episode but I was thinking you know what
I would like to nominate myself to be
Bethenny's friend because I think I'd be
great at it I think he would be great at
it too and we'll get there trust me he
will get there I'm dedicating here but I
completely agree with you and but there
are people in Hollywood who's like
liberate their full-time jobs are being
like star-fuckers and people usually
think that means like having sex with
celebrities and it does but it's also
just like kissing you like kissing ass
like just being like an enabler it's
like you know like there are certain
people who like your only friend there
are only friends of you because they
know what they can get out of you right
and celebrities just like are always
like I think somebody's are like wildly
insecure and they just surround
themselves everyone's hanging out with
you because like Miami and you know what
that's true and we would be hanging out
with you too because you're a celebrity
but at least you know you could trust us
right and if you like the fact that like
we're just like such a family it's like
we know loyalty but that you always
that's it that's so true and that's what
they think about when I think of Taylor
Swift because I find it so interesting
that like her mom and it's not it's not
uncommon for like someone's mom to be
their manager but her mom's not her
manager like her mom is just like her
mom gee I mean that's her role on the
tour right and the fact that she like
Taylor Swift needs her mothering the
fact that through all of this now let's
starting from like her little purple
dress at the speaking out or to like
literally selling out stadiums and that
her mom's at every show it's like
there's something so grounding about
just like being around like having your
family and you can always tell like when
things go wrong when like people aren't
talking to their family anymore and I
think that's also part of the reason of
the Kardashian's success one because
like their family has kept them grounded
and two because watching a family be a
family and go through the ups and downs
and like ups and downs that we could
never even say them like I think is so
relatable and that's why I've even when
Kim dumped Kris Humphries on the side of
the road and I hated her like I still
liked watching the show because they're
just such a family unit and they've
gotten as far as they are because aside
from the rob like disloyal blac Chyna I
think they've stayed like a unit and
they've been so loyal to one another and
like that's a thing with Hollywood you
cannot trust anyone
right I see it so it's like just so
important to have it someone yeah but
that's why we nominate ourselves to be
like if you're celebrity and you need
like a good loyal friend who's a good
time but also knows when enough is
enough
calling us who's gonna like you for you
because I feel like unless you like
Stocking if we are not funny and your
personality stinks then we don't want to
hang out with you but you know if you're
a cool like we get along with everyone
everyone I feel like everyone who meets
us is just like those girls are so fun
and so nice mostly everyone mostly well
yeah unless you're not found a nice yeah
totally I wonder what people say about
us when they know I've only heard good
things but I guess I wouldn't hear the
bad thing no I I know that there's two
immediate reactions to meeting me and I
totally understand them both which are
first it's like oh my god she's
hilarious she's so crazy she's funny
she's a good time like she seems cool
and obviously I understand that and then
there are people who meet me and just
think I'm like the most annoying loud
I'm not just you which girl I ever met
and I totally get that too and like I
understand her sorry but that just means
they haven't actually metalloid a loud
annoying I'm not just Jewish girl
because there were their worst and there
they are worse than me they even put you
to shame
totally but I don't I don't disagree
with that um that perception of me
they're not wrong and I totally
understand that like my brand is not for
everyone
hey so when people like literally hate
me and like they say mean things about
me online like I don't think they're bad
people I think they really really in
their souls just like hate me
like think that I'm a bad person and
like they're not doing anything wrong
and hating me they're justified because
they think that I'm like this evil
person right you know what I mean I knew
the other side the other side the other
side like I always say like if I ever
came like Ren into like my biggest hater
I would just like literally go out to
dinner at them cuz I think like I don't
think that these haters are like bad
people I think they really feel like
they're doing the right thing and hating
in hating me and they think that I'm
like I go home and I take this mask off
and I'm really like this evil person and
I put on this front and so I can't
explain I don't fault I think about all
the time I don't fault people who hate
me for hating me I think they really
think they're doing the right you say
don't know you so like right I always
say like I would want to take my biggest
hater out to dinner because then they
realize it was all girls world people
you know again we're all cool just
trying to get by and this yeah the world
totally so I don't know how we got to
that but we should become friends in
celebrities we should become friends
with celebrity speaking of Demi Lovato
support system Wilmer Valderrama visited
her in the hospital after her overdose
so people have shift to the core because
everyone ships then yeah I think he was
really good for her and her sobriety he
seems so normal
he does and it's just so crazy like he
was like the subject of so many
celebrity angles and fights and he was
in every tablet a very good lady
everyone like they just were clamoring
for him and it's like Demi Lovato just
woke up one morning and the second got
him you ready I think about that all the
time it's so underrated I thought people
forget like what a heartthrob he was yes
because he's like not now yeah I read
something on Instagram and it definitely
could have been fake but what I had seen
is that the last time Jamie was living
in a rehab facility Miley was like one
of the first people to go visit her and
what they're saying is that Miley has
now visited Demi in the hospital but
that was like an Instagram post from
like a Demi fan account which weirdly
like has a lot of validity to it
but I just thought if that did happen I
really liked ship them up there I think
they are true friends Miley is also a
great friend for her except that like
Miley isn't sober but she's more sober
than she used to be Miley doesn't smoke
weed anymore
that's nice but she drinks yeah like I
know I think Miley like went through her
crazy phase and I think Miley feels
grateful that it didn't go the way that
it could of like the way it went for
Demi and I think Miley like now
it's like so I mean I don't know
anything I don't know her but this is
just about that I get like she went
through that crazy phase and yes the
worst thing she did was like smoke weed
and like she'll like be like a [ __ ] like
on with her outfits but like she is
poppin Molly
oh well Shay and it's in some okay but
it's in every song oh I guess but she
was like a teen idol scene you know
totally but it sounded like Miley it
could have went so much like Molly the
country what are we talking about oh
yeah people thought she was saying Miley
yeah
dancin with Molly what is it the
population of Molly I think it's dancing
with Miley herself dancing with Molly
it's Milas she wants us to ask these
questions um that because that was even
we can't stop before she really went off
the deep end
before I her dead pet right but so what
I'm saying is that I think Miley like is
smart enough now and has like the
hindsight to realize like that could
have been Miley right and I think also
it has a lot to do with like your
chemical disposition to like addiction
and so I just think some people are like
predisposed right like family history so
and Demi is and I think my that came out
the other side and like she just doesn't
have that sort of addictive person right
that would lead her to trouble I just
like I really am living for the unity
and camaraderie around like people just
supporting Demi yeah it's like I didn't
realize it but I think she's the only
person who's just universally well-liked
in Hollywood by all celebrities like
except for her weird beef with Selena
Gomez but apparently Selena Gomez visit
devastated yeah oh D yeah cuz you just
if you had told like if you had asked me
like who's someone in Hollywood like if
they god forbid like died everyone would
be like devastated and everyone would be
affected I like couldn't I wouldn't be
able to think of anyone but now that I
think about it like Demi Lovato was that
person like she really is like everyone
in Hollywood they've all definitely
struggled with some sort of addiction so
they they feel for her and the fact that
she's so open about it it's like
impressive and inspiring and I don't
know I just love that everyone is just
like surrounding it surrounding her yeah
and we are too and if anyone in Tami's
camp is watching me are serious about
being her friend yeah we'll be fantastic
and we really will we will and you know
I think that like we all saw this coming
a little bit she was dealing with like a
lot of weird like drama with her blogger
friend with her life coach yeah like
it's like a therapist and I think if
like you know if you're fighting with
your therapist it's cause like you don't
want to hear what they have to say
yeah and then when she was leaving the
club like it was that okay next up we
have some business tech news and it's
really it's what everyone's talking
about it's a judo
it's a two-parter Facebook loses a
quarter of its earnings after its Valley
loses a quarter of its value after
dismal earnings yes so crazy there's a
stock went down ever since the year 2000
Facebook has been on the rise up and up
however shares of Facebook continue to
plunge Thursday wiping nearly 150
billion dollars from its market cap in
just hours after the company's CFO
forecasts a significant drop in revenue
growth and margins in the coming
quarters quote looking beyond 2018 we
anticipate the total expense growth will
exceed revenue growth in 2019 said CFO
David winner on a conference call
Wednesday over the next several years we
would anticipate that our operating
margins will trend towards the mid-30s
on a percentage basis when his comments
on the conference call came after
facebook said revenues grew less than
expected in the second quarter and its
user count missed estimates the
statements accelerated losses in the
stock which was down as much as 24%
after-hours this is a mage I mean
Facebook is still number one big thing
like money ads on their videos yeah ads
on their videos and then it's like
brands spend so much money on these oh
right sell your info and you know when
you're thinking of something and then
you see an ad for it someone sends you
something then you see an adequate piece
you know how much they spend to get in
your head and they sell your data they
sell your data but the morning cause it
is not selling your data no no no so
this is a brand new contrast there's a
part of the whole company yeah they're
gonna get us a cup
soon by us honestly that's weird that's
a go
anyways I think this is just nice
pinnable so monumental that this is like
thanks because reach the tipping point
yeah and if I matter at peak Facebook
which i think is a good thing and I
think if you guys to think about it as
not only Facebook as Facebook Instagram
whatsapp whatever else they own like
it's just so crazy it's so crazy but I
think I think it's a good thing that
this is as big as it's gonna get for
Facebook because it's very very big and
they're too powerful they have too much
power and like just the whole world is
on Facebook and you know what you got
like now Alexis in our home
and that's what we're gonna give her our
information instead now ya know Alexa
totally is listening to me Alexa listen
to everything and even when you put her
on me you like what's to stop her from
listening from me how do we know she's
meeting herself and you know what like I
just and here's the thing about people
selling my information it's like okay
you want to sell the fact that I listen
to the best of both worlds right I'm
repeat for two days like you do it's
Alaba yeah you know like there's really
not what you want to sell like my
conversation with Zach about what we're
gonna order for dinner right okay but I
guess you don't realize like all the
stuff that happens in your house no but
like say they like I Adam at a spy right
like I but we hide out the way a secret
information in my home when I was like
when the Snowden stuff happened I don't
really know what happened something just
about like stealing your information
like I've never eked what they do with
your information he leaked like stuff
that what he liked he leaked here's a
traitor and a hero because he works for
like it's his job to write to protect to
keep his our lips are sealed
did you ever see the Mary Kate Nash in
movie so what these are my thoughts like
I've always thought like you know if
Verizon wants to like you know listen in
on my conversations just so that if they
listen in to the conversation of a
terrorist like they could you know help
you know so I've never I'm okay to
forego my privacy a little bit for the
greater good but then it's like let's
say I like smoke pot and like I'm on the
phone with like a drug dealer like are
you gonna use that against me now like
no on January 7th you got pot do you
know what I mean yeah it's like a petty
petty theft do you know right but it's
like why would they care right no so I'm
just saying like I'll open up my legs to
Verizon as long as like they're not
gonna incriminate me right but then like
the terrorists could say the same thing
you know I don't know it's tough you
guys and I think that's what you know
the whole government is struggling with
and you know these private companies so
we're not alone in that knowing how to
feel about it yeah I feel two ways I'm
on like I feel to me I'm like I have the
time I'm like whatever I don't even I'm
not even that interesting and then some
of the times I realize like I had a lot
going on and I don't need people like
listening in and I've become way
paranoid look sometimes I like well like
check something [ __ ] and I'll
literally delete that cuz like I don't
want that in my do you do anything yeah
like something nasty it's really just
crazy but at this point like if you are
on social media have a phone for ten
years blah blah blah like all your stuff
has been collected at this point
I'll keep that right they've got you and
also like what you're just gonna not use
a phone anymore and like become Amish
like that's just a really big life
change and that's hard to remember so is
having your information leaked anyways
it's really tough but also Facebook did
have all of those like breaches with
information and they were using it
properly and you know what now this
doesn't shock me this doesn't shock me
and you got to pay the piper
speaking of paying piper our next story
is that Massacre burger loss are barking
black Zuckerberg I want to say weird so
he doesn't know we're talking about him
we need a code name for him suck okay
I'm sure that's what his friends calling
yeah Mark Zuckerberg this is eighteen
point eight billion dollars in just two
hours and drops from fourth to eighth in
the world's rich list after Facebook
reveals slow as ever growth in users
like that is just so embarrassing
imagine he's like with all of his
billionaire friends and it's like but so
he loses it eighteen what does he have
you think like how much money does Mark
Zuckerberg have in his chase account
Zuckerberg net worth went from eighty
two point four billion to sixty three
point six billion on Wednesday let's see
net worth means nothing right because
these are all just like molecules of
numbers because face like the internet
is just like relator no but net worth
and this is why I like I don't believe
like it says on the internet my net
worth is two hundred and seventy five
thousand dollars but let me tell you I
do not have that in my bank account but
they value the businesses that I own and
like I guess if I owned cars or whatever
I'm like invested in they value that at
two hundred seventy five thousand like
my Instagram account is definitely worth
money people trying buy it all the time
this show is something worth something
and I guess me as a whole like if you
want to buy me you would have to pay two
hundred seven five grand which doesn't
seem like a lot no it really doesn't
but then also I saw that Teresa Giudice
is net worth is negative eleven million
with a photo of Kim Zolciak so I
wouldn't trust online net more
celebritynetworth.com is definitely not
a reputable site but I trust Mark
Zuckerberg is net worth in the daily
mail right cuz his company's public he
has to report everything and if I were
him I'd just be so pissed like imagine I
feel like he like could be like a little
cheap and so he's probably like thinking
about getting like a house and he was
like you know what we're not gonna do it
like do you remember blaze he's five
million like we can't afford right now
and we lost 18 when he was like building
a house and like putting a wall around
it yeah that was weird did you see that
story about Matt Lauer's house in New
Zealand
you put it in our group chat and I
didn't read it okay yes it is the
strangest story Matt Lauer purchased a
plot of land in New Zealand very
beautiful expansive before his disgrace
and fought him race and the gun you know
when you're an assault or you really
shouldn't be making big purchases right
you never know when the ground could be
pulled out from underneath you right and
it and it has been and so part of that
land is like part of like National Park
uh-huh and he said like he worked out
with the government that like he would
leave some of it opens like foot traffic
so that because it's very expansive like
acreage yeah and like people trailers
couldn't like pass through hikers and
now like the government is saying that
he needs to open the roads to like
public transportation and so like that's
not cool and he's like no yeah but
because he's Matt Lauer him saying no is
like everyone else it yeah there were a
lot of girls who said no to didn't mean
anything so that's all right that's not
right I mean it's just you can't change
the rules when the person ready bought
the house right but then I guess in New
Zealand they also have a closet like if
you're uh if you're doing business with
the government and you're like or buying
a home in the country and you're like
cited for bad behavior like in the world
they have like a bad behavior they read
from and they could take it his home
away it's a place right they need to
play by their rules to god it was just
like sell the land you need to save your
money like I don't think don't be
getting another to sell its Ella yeah so
no I'm talking Matt Lauer's gonna come
back to today you think so mmm-hmm how
so in what see in what sort of capacity
I don't know NBC is so corrupt like and
he was there for so long and as much as
he was like totally an assaulter he like
everyone there loves him it's crazy like
even though he's literally like the
terrible person
um NBC is just like riddled with
corruption they don't care and he's a
man so he could do whatever he wants
he's gonna be back on TV mark my words
that would be so crazy I'll I'll dispute
that with it I'll fight the fight when
it comes yeah right now it's just like
wearing that weather at your wedding
like I'm not gonna worry about yes he
thinks this will all pass like
eventually but if we don't if we don't
stop talking about it then I can't pass
that's true and like New Zealand is not
letting it pass look what he did to
Tamron Hall she deserves true justice
totally okay this next story I'm so
interested by okay so the website hopper
HQ has put out the Instagram Rich List
of 2018 the people on Instagram who are
making the most money and how much they
make per post
am I on it no and it's wrong Oh
because you're not on extract choose not
on it but the rest so I guess they
forgot like comics or mean accounts with
Reddington so just put that away for a
second we that's so annoying
no so annoying just Minister first thing
I look for who was number one Kylie
Jenner of makes a million dollars per
post does that mean a bread would pay
her a million dollars yeah so if she's
posting a picture well I guess certain
brands like she does like 50 or sugar
bear hair and they buy a bundle right
because she does a couple different
posts I'm sure they get a good rate um
but I guess if you were like Kylie I
want you to post about the morning totes
on your Instagram I would have she
really would have to pay her
crowdfunding and where they still find
if we started a Kickstarter like if we
could just get a million people to
500,000 people okay
what's a million / five twenty thousand
people to give us five dollars 25 that
twenty twenty thousand to two hundred
thousand two hundred thousand people to
give us $5 then we could pick highly and
then the show would be like so let do
min business would be boomin nobody
let's do it okay we're paying her
million dollars we need her on the show
and then we want her to promote that
episode afterwards yeah we'll work that
in second is Selena Gomez who gets paid
$800,000 per post
well Selena Gomez is the most followed
person on that story right her and Kim
go back and forth Christina Christiano
Ronaldo gets paid 750,000 per post well
you know what that makes sense cuz I
feel like it's not even about his
followers it's just more about his clout
yeah also he has more followers than Kim
and Kylie how many does he have 133
million
Selena Gomez has 138 million Kylie
Jenner has 110 million Kim is number
four she has a hundred and thirteen
million and she makes seven hundred and
twenty thousand per post that's so crazy
cuz like Kourtney would do something for
the 250 right wait keeps going beyond
say 700 K per post but Beyonce doesn't
do sponsored post on her Instagram
maybe she does and just that native no
she doesn't even ever have a caption I
understand I don't follow her site I
check it out every once in a while the
rock 650 K believeth Justin Bieber 630 k
Neymar da Silva Santos jr. is a soccer
player I guess got it he makes 600 K
Lionel Messi makes 500 K which is crazy
that in the top 10 there are three
soccer soccer player soccer is not even
a big sport in the States like that just
goes to this America no this is the
world yeah so but no but like soccer is
a big deal in the world right and it's
see how like it's not even a big deal
here but like literally we're so minut
in the gray that still the top three are
soccer players keep going numbers we're
like the influencer never really you can
break it down by category which will do
but number 10 is kendall Jenner 500,000
number 11 is Khloe good for her 480 k12
is David Beckham 300k and now we get
into a bunch of people who I don't know
Garrus coil where's Courtney Courtney is
not here so far well I mean I don't
follow her me neither her Instagram
stories suck and like the only time your
Instagram is good is when she's on
vacation and a news post every photo
yeah so I don't feel it okay now now I
want to see my liberty beauty fashion
Fitness food lifestyle sport of traveled
I want influencer like do fashion
fashion number one Bella Hadid she makes
27k proposed that's celebrity I want
influencer okay the third number then
second is M Radha
third is Chiara frog knee yeah but she's
like turn into like a full foot she
makes nineteen point five K from one
post for one post uh number six on
fashion is Camilla hi ho she makes ten
thousand seven hundred and fifty hours I
think she makes more that these numbers
are starting to sound low you know
Chiara frog me doing for nineteen
thousand is not a lot and Camilla has
seven point two million followers and
she post premium content I follow her
and I meet you know she's a real evolved
girl she definitely makes more than that
so these numbers Alexa Chung they say
makes $4,500 a post that's not true yeah
wait where is Olivia culpo she maybe
she's under beauty and growing a beauty
now number one is who de who makes 33 K
/ oh my god she by the way she is so
rich who de no is being smart [ __ ] okay
lifestyle
number one is still Hooda number two is
Lele pons making 32k a post I think she
might make more she definitely makes
more and I've never seen a sponsored
post on her page she makes two all for
money on YouTube that's amazing and like
she's like as in movies and music videos
Logan calling J power 7 and 8 for
lifestyle and they make 17 K it is this
on Instagram only yes okay um
we gotta find Olivia culpo she's in
fashion then if she's not there this is
how I know this list is fake because no
well they only give you top 10 for the
subcategories unless they download the
press pack no don't do it don't know no
can you search people or no I don't
think
travel like but like where's she
Mitchell do you think the points guys on
here let's see he would be on travel
Yeshe Mitchell is definitely it needs to
be on this list Garrett and Jessica G
are number one and I haven't thought who
they are but the toasters post about
them all the time I guess it's the guy
with like the long hair check you know
that's Savannah and Jackson whatever his
name is why they hate the bucket list
family you know that's 23 K proposed the
people they never have any objective the
twisters the people that the trust was
always talking about other LeBrons let
me see it okay see if I know any of
these isn't this just tall and eclairs
you know I don't know any of these yeah
I know Lauren Bullen gypsy lost she's
per day this is wild let's go back to
all also in top 10 for beauty was like
James Charles oh I like I mean I am I
just want to see but I think that
they're missing a lot of people and I
think same I think they went a lot by
followers when it's like there are
people who have so much influence right
like on the up-and-up people I who have
a million followers and get 5,000 likes
can make just as much money a post as
people with 500,000 followers but that
get 20,000 likes it's all about it's
about of your engagement it's not about
your fault it's a we're saying that
Martha Stewart makes twenty five hundred
dollars a post but that's just not true
right like I think that Olivia culpo
would be like a mirror or above Alexa
Chung but Olivia culpo is not here see
they're not in tune with what's
necessary Oh Yolanda camp
she's great had a cake get you follow
her no this is so interesting but it's a
lie yeah but I do believe the Chi at the
top a tight end yeah tab 10 Wow
interesting okay very interesting I just
forget that Beyonce has a last name I
was like I think she wants you to forget
yeah it's like she wasn't as Madonna in
wonder she is okay our fifth and final
story which will propel is sorry
speaking of Beyonce when I was in Denver
I'd like the whole day on t know I'd the
whole day to do nothing and I was just
like laying in bed watching blow Jack
and after below-deck was over this movie
started playing on Bravo with Beyonce in
it and it wasn't Dreamgirls I hadn't
ever seen it it was interest Alba and
Beyonce I think I tell Jackie it is the
most incredible movie I've ever seen I
can't believe I've never even heard of
it I was literally wrapped up in this
movie it just started and I was like
gonna change a channel then I'll be out
to him I that's interesting
they're like moving into this house
that's a sofa and they play this like a
glamorous like a rich couple and I'm
like what is going on here Zelda has
like this and then Ali Larter is in it
and she plays this like [ __ ]
it is upset I've usually I mean I've
used the word [ __ ] twice today and I
never really use that word and it's a
territory to see and I'm sorry I take it
back
Jackie it's the most unbelievable movie
it's like it's like a classic story line
that you would think was like cheesy and
stupid but it's so well done Ali Larter
is insane
and that Kermie often go at it at the
end it's the most incredible movie ever
and I just think everyone should see it
I love like hearing or seeing movies
that like I didn't even you know like
yeah so rarely like surprised it's like
there's one good movie a month and not
only that they've never even heard of
yeah like shutter island' exactly and
shutter island has sparked so much
conversation like within our family
within the toasters and it's just like
I'm so glad that we contributed to
people watching something other than
like the kissing booth totally and sorry
and I really kind of retain it like a
real conversation starter also back to
my movie oh by the movies called Sesto
sorry back to my film I also just feel
like a Juris Elvis a good guy and I like
want to support him do you know what I
mean and I feel like he was robbed
because he was opposed to be James Bond
and then what happened and then that guy
didn't quit Oh
Daniel Craig and it's like I'm not like
Daniel Craig is literally McCain but
he's still in his prime like it could
still happen nobody how you see the
trailer for Aquaman no oh my god I
didn't even know it came out but I
absolutely love Jason Momoa mama I love
him so much the trailers amazing and
Amber Heard like wears a red wig and at
the end like she said number herdsman
yeah she loved her love interest and at
the end of the trailer I guess she like
jumps out of the plane without a
parachute and he goes redheads gotta
love him so Aquaman is what by the way
I'm it's so weird because Aquaman did
you yes I know I like a storyline in
Entourage where Vinnie gets like the
role of Aquaman I like it changes his
whole life that's gonna be Jason Momoa
and I can't think of anyone more
deserving or more hot by the way I feel
like when he was kicked up I mean sorry
if you would never watch Game of Thrones
like sorry when he doesn't eat well if
you found him an Instagram then you know
what's that
but I feel like everyone was absolutely
devastated for sure but then we heard he
was gonna be an Aquaman and like we were
fine with it
but he died five years ago like why does
Aquaman take so long these movies
long time and then also he was in
Justice League mhm so it's like all the
heroes Oh was he not anything that
Marvel money so we got a taste of him
and I watched Justice League and like
and now it made me really excited for
Aquaman a movie which I would never see
it for Jason Momoa and it's not for
Wonder Woman being in Justice League
which is why I gave it a shot because I
saw Wonder Woman which was so wonderful
right I haven't seen it and any one of
those but you should watch Wonder Woman
it's just like I love God without and
I'll support her like in everything
except watching Wonder Woman I just
don't have the time but I think you'll
enjoy it and she's so weird right now
like you don't even have to listen watch
it without sound no I can okay fifth and
final story which will propel us into
the next segment of the show Carol rads
well is leading the Real Housewives of
New York I'm so she released a statement
that was like beyond condescending did
you see like I'll focus on my journalism
after six years of robbers her Honi I've
decided to return what I do best
journalism and producing and being mean
to Bethany grads well said on Wednesday
in a statement two Bravo's daily dish
I'm sure this does not come as a
surprise to any of the viewers because
they all hate me all of you who have
been supported encouraging and kind my
original curiosity curiosity curiosity
about reality TV has waned over the
years especially because now people
don't like me because I turned on
Bethany because I got too big for my
britches and I'm focusing on TV and
writing projects that better suit my
more steady temperament and I can live
out my dream of being a sad Carrie
Bradshaw okay I find the timing of this
to be wildly interesting yeah because I
know the jury is still out on this
season right but now that she's gone
it's like she lost she's proving us
right even though the battle is still
waging there has not been one yet the
war it's not been but now it has it has
but like the the vibe that I get and I
know nothing I'd have no insider
information is that I think the ladies
they get a couple episodes in advance
and I think Carol must have seen this
week's episode next week's episode and
just realize that not only was she
acting poorly but editing was not on her
side like at all so I think she knew how
catastrophic it could be and for some
reason like her quitting before me
seeing her be terrible like it softens
the blow a little bit I'm like well
whatever she's gone so let's just get
through the season it was kind of like a
smart strategic move in terms of the
timing but I just I feel like the way
she's acting the season it's clear that
like she is has lost a little bit of
self-awareness
yeah and she really thinks that
he's right and so like for her to be
watching it back I don't see her being
like oh my gosh I was wrong I can't
imagine her ever thinking or uttering
the words I was I don't think she thinks
she's wrong I think that she was she
thinks she was wrong duh but that all
people are gonna see is her acting
poorly when she thinks that she was
justified but like do you know what I
mean but it's one thing to think you're
right but it's another thing to see you
being literally so mean I wouldn't take
her for a quitter like this and honestly
it made me like her even less I thought
maybe she would at least come out
swinging it wasn't until last night's
episode that the tide really turned for
Team Bethenny because last week people
and the toasters were still 50/50 last
night's poll and watch our happens I'd
showed that the majority of people are
team Bethenny I did one on my on my
Instagram because I really just wanted
to know because there's first of all
this is a season we deserve like it's
it's just it's so our time and I had
like a visceral physical reaction to
this episode like I was just so invested
like I couldn't sleep because I couldn't
stop thinking about it
and I was just I can't even wrap my head
around someone disagreeing with me right
now do you know what I mean right
so I did this story I'm like I just I
really truly want to know like am I
crazy or does everyone agree with me so
I said who what to what side are you on
are you side Bethenny Sonja LuAnn for
everyone else Carole jorinda Tinsley got
4,000 votes Bethenny so Neil Amman got
18,000 votes so it wasn't the percentage
was 81 19 oh wow that's pretty much what
it was I might run up inside you but I
don't think it was until this episode
that so many people really took this
side because sometimes in housewives
it's not about who's right it's just
about who you like and then you just
start arguing on their behalf right and
I that definitely is that's the Erica
Jean syndrome yeah we all stuff like
sometimes she's not right but I just I
don't care and I'll defend her because I
like her but I'm not even why I feel so
she even more strongly that Bethenny is
right is because I don't stand her like
I do Erica so for me to feel so strongly
in defense of her it's like wow she must
really be being wronged right and I feel
like people last week who were defending
Carole just like really like Carole and
like the same thing we do with others
just like we're defending them blindly
but then like this week sometimes a
housewife does stuff that like you just
you can't say unforgivable but I mean
during this teetering that line
let's never sewed it as housewives was
one of these episodes like scary island
like the medium dinner your husband will
never emotionally fulfill you one of
these iconic Housewives episodes that
like if you want to convince someone why
housewives are so good last night's
episode is one of those there was not a
minute of filler total every line every
and it was all in one day
so you know they they were just like oh
[ __ ] happen they filmed until like they
never filmed them when they come back
from dinner yeah Dorinda with her Joker
smile like yeah they filmed from the
morning that they woke up Bethenny
didn't want to go shopping until that
night and so there's so much there and I
don't think that it made me feel like
they're not editing [ __ ] they really
like to show us as much as possible and
I thought that this episode was the boat
episode and honestly I don't even think
the boat episode could be better than
this episode because I heard they have
no footage and they keep showing the
same one scene with Sonja holding Ramona
crying like I think that they really
thought they were gonna die and they had
to cut everything and they don't have
anything from that from the footage yeah
which would be fine by me because I'm
going on a boat soon and I'm not even
invested like this whole season I've
been waiting for like the boat the boat
the boat I'm not invested in that what's
happening with the people on the boat is
way more just anything I think the boat
might ruin some of the promise that
means maybe yeah people will start to
put things into perspective of me like
okay we don't need to be fighting but
yes you do okay LuAnn do not forget for
you during that even though I want to
start from the beginning and I don't
want to I don't want to miss anything
okay so we dream Bethenny crying in the
fridge which I don't know why she was in
the freezer it was very hot she was
wiping her armpits okay she was sweating
Dorinda was like comforting her and then
talking [ __ ] about her in the other side
commentary and then all the ladies left
which I think was the right thing I
agree um and they were just having this
conversation
I [ __ ] love Sonja like her unwavering
support for Bethenny and you said this
last night if Bethenny ever ever again I
there's one mean word to or about Sonja
I will never forgive her because she
would be broken down if it wasn't for
Sonja and she ready is broken down but
Sonja was for someone who's never really
had a coherent thing to say she is so
articulate lucid and so right and she's
just battling everyone she's taking
everyone on like she's unapologetically
on Bethenny side and that's like a real
friend
and if Bethenny ever ever utters a mean
word about Sonja ever again
I will never ever forgive her again and
I will never forget how I feel right now
even in two seasons from now cuz I still
don't forget cheater brand wait or say
she was very rough Bethenny turns on so
for some [ __ ] I'm done with her Sam
I know I'm gonna save this clip so that
we don't go back on it yeah so she's
crying in the freezer all the ladies
left and they have like this really mean
nasty conversation about how like she's
so toxic and it's like I feel like
especially in this franchise whenever
someone's like acting out they always
find a reason to be like you know she
they're going through stuff and it's
always like [ __ ] stuff like her
daughter went to college like that's
like going through stuff that's life
but Bethany is someone who's actually
going through legit [ __ ] literally has a
restraining order against her ex-husband
who is the devil and took all of her
money took her house and takes her kid
every other weekend and is trying to get
half custody like he's so insane she's
always so rebuilding an entire country
right
she's going through like legitimate [ __ ]
and no one could care less and what
really is wrong like what really bothers
me about Carol ish
she said Bethany having a breakdown it's
it's unnerving to watch like because
there's no reason for it she has a nice
life oh wait she has nice planes right
so there's no apparent reason for her to
have a breakdown which is so [ __ ] up
because carol was the only one who knew
how bad it was with Jesus in the thick
of it and last season she would give us
taste Civic Joe so that we could
understand Bethany a little bit more
like she was doing what Sonia's doing
like she was telling the group I don't
even think Sonja knows how bad it was
because Kyle went through it with
Bethany's or year yeah he's like that
there's no apparent reason for her to
have a breakdown when we know that you
know even more what we don't know yeah
makes me dislike her even more
no like I just every time you think
Carol can't say something even worse she
does and then like literally in that
store which rather I was so cute she's
saying there was horrible things and
Bethany's listening she can hear she's
like it's just it's so uncomfortable for
me to be around someone who can't stop
crying like a six-year-old but like but
but no one even stops to think for one
second like maybe she's upset you know
like she's not crying cuz she wants to
and she and she's so shy and she never
shows emotion and it's not I like it's
not even just the Jason stuff that's
what's so crazy is like if it were just
that it would still be so much but when
she's crying in the kitchen saying she's
her life is like scheduled within an
inch of her life like she has no time
like she has taken on so much which also
it's like then why did you have to make
skinny girl jeans like no one needed
that right that's just another thing
like but the holy country is
pending on her and sound like she can
just slow down because then like people
don't get their food right no no like
totally and just everyone's like lack of
empathy is beyond just because this
troop of women who've known each other
for so long are always like cutting each
other breaks being like she was going
through a hard time you know like and
Bethany is actually going through a hard
time and so many different friends and I
have to say something that I mean I
figured this day would come I just
didn't know it would be today but I'm
officially I'm done with Tinsley because
you it's not even for any reason that
you were thinking like yeah like she's
silly and the wedding dress is it's all
very silly but that's who she is and you
know it she brings kind of a freshness
to the show but first of all her
presence on the show is like Bristol
Palin joining Teen Mom right now like
would have been great ten years ago I'm
over it
second of all her and her glam teen and
all of her looks in carta Hannya it's a
little like embarrassing I agree and
they're in this house which I'm sorry is
not good enough for Real Housewives like
we've seen all the houses their [ __ ]
house in Mexico in Turks and Caicos in
st. Barts like this is just doesn't meet
the level like when the lands feet were
journey that was insane like she's like
lift up your feet like this house is not
the caliber of housewife acceptability
and heard with her glam squad in her
tiny room with no air conditioning is
like a joke I mean you're like a
beautiful young girl like just no she's
the last person who needs it relax like
she can't relax she's looking at herself
from like and that does not make a good
reality TV person because we need to see
the real you and I do think that like
the real her is fun and sweet and like a
little naive which I like about her but
she's not giving any of that and like
know her like harsh looks it's like I
can still trying like way too hard to be
a housewife and her and Ramona were
relatively in the middle in terms of
everything like Tinsley did not
interject for one second into the
Bethany and Carroll drama but she's a
very smart but then which we'll talk
about at the end watch happens live
Ramona goes in on Bethany and she's like
totally team Carol even though she
didn't really say anything and during
this episode stuff more stuff might have
happened yeah okay so they're in this
store and then Bethany when they go to
lunch it's like about to go home and I'm
so glad she didn't it would have been if
she went home it's completely justified
no one wanted her there and she did want
to be there so the ladies couldn't have
been mad she did them a favor no but
then like just I was thinking of the
scene when they go back to New York and
she has to crawl on her Anthony's I'm
sorry living shouldn't have done it that
way no and I'm just so glad we don't
have to deal with that totally she made
the right decision being like it would
be a big hoopla bigger than me crying at
lunch so like that
was so uncomfortable the three ladies go
and it's just Ramona LuAnn the OGS and
that was like a cute scene that was the
key scene and that was nut meaning guys
when they showed that scene of like
Tinsley tubing glam like three times a
day for three hours that's what made me
realize like you know what um I'm gonna
step out onto sleep for now I think I
could come back to her yeah maybe next
season but just like for now she's on
the wrong side of history she's taking
too long to get ready it's losing
premium content for us and it looks like
aren't even amazing like when Erika
Jayne takes three hours to get ready
like the looks are there well here's the
thing I'm not against housewives
bringing clam squats like when they're
in Dubai like and like everything is
extra glam like their rooms have fish
tanks like you gotta bring a glam squad
but in this little shack in Carter Kenya
like you don't need a full blast pot I
bet the hotel that her glam squad
staying at is nicer than the house
here's here's gonna meet my lot if the
house has a/c you can either glass yeah
if it doesn't no need you're gonna sweat
off your meat and the more time we spend
in card to henna I'm like this house I
mean I just can't believe after that
literally after I watched last night's
episode I was like I'm never going to
card ahead yeah yeah you're going to
Columbia next week it's literally this
is the worst commercial for car tenia
because it's like a very like people go
there people I know weather all the time
in staying like these beautiful I don't
know why they're staying in like this
street corner in this like town house I
will not I will not be coming it's not a
good question if you're going there like
after this ok so then they're all
getting ready for dinner and Sonia looks
so [ __ ] cute so she looks you so so
good like her body looks amazing her
outfit is unbelievably cute she's in
gist it's like mental state that I never
want her to leave I agree and like her
standing barely enough her pink lace top
her pink hot shorts against the purple
wall of her bedroom like was a moment I
feel like this is a weird thing to say
but I feel like the Sonia now is the
Sonia that her ex-husband fell in love
with like fun-loving funny like not so
serious you know what I mean yeah and
like not this era of delusion that we've
been seeing right which was caused
partially by like this lifestyle she was
living that was then pulled out from
underneath right but now she's got a
great life back she's getting 30 came on
from her townhouse
yeah like she'll be okay yeah and
honestly I think it's such a it's so
impressive how much she's been able to
hide her daughter cuz like Brynn is
completely hidden and I know exactly
what she looks like it's Tony's daughter
literally came up to me and sat on my
face I wouldn't know she was that is
crazy
and there's like no papa rock there's
nothing no cuz I guess because she like
goes to boarding school in the village
you know it's honestly good for Sonia um
and if you like Sonia was like if they
did
I feel like the Morgans do not want the
kid on the show so like she was scared
straight yeah okay so then Carol comes
in to Sonja's room with weird earrings
that by the way it really helped out but
I thought it was I thought they looked
really cute I know what she needed was
the allison lulu side earrings yes but
the color turquoise and pink is so cute
together I don't know I just she was
having a total pink moment I didn't
think she needed anything else but I'm
also a minimalist when it comes to
jewelry that was weird because she was
like I got everyone earrings but I don't
see anyone else with earrings right and
also like her intentions were very
strange you know and by the way she was
upfront with her attention she was like
I want to know what's going on but like
why does she keep acting like she's
missing something like she's like
something's happened that she doesn't
know about you know very well what
happened and what neither of them are
saying it's like really people do just
like grow apart and so it and when you
grow apart with someone you've been
super close with there's always like
this awkwardness until you address it
and they addressed it in like a rage
filled way that like made it into a
bigger fight than it had to if they did
address it back at that restaurant in
New York and know here's the thing I
think when you're super close with
someone you let them and they know
everything about your life then you'd
ripped apart I don't think there's any
being acquaintances they know too much
and it's like we've chosen not to be
close because of some whatever reason
we've grown apart
and I just think it's the friendship is
over at that point I don't think it's
like we go from being best friends you
know everything about my life to
acquaintances we just say hi it's like
an ex-boyfriend yeah you can't be
friends with an ex they know everything
about you they've seen you naked like
hold I'm not just gonna like go to lunch
with you totally and Sony did a good job
of just explaining to Carroll Cowell's
and I want to hear it basically she was
like that he feels like he want nothing
to do with her and by the way not that's
not unjustified you've literally made it
so clear you want nothing to do with
Bethenny and by the way that's fine I
just don't understand why Carol wants
nothing to do with Bethenny you know
like right like what did she have to
gain from not being with Bethenny she
has more to gain as being friends with
Bethenny and also like she could still
live her tensley 20-year old life ready
friends with Bethenny so like why did
she have to give up Bethenny like
fortunately Brett did Bethenny posed to
her and so what maybe just all of the
nice citations were too much no yeah
that was so shady and they pulled up
pictures and but then Ramona said on
watched up inside that Carole paid her
way for all those trips but I don't 75
private you think she's gonna charge
Carole for the plane with the Charter
and yeah totally and Adam I mean he's
America's house guest he's America's
house
I mean I think Carol would pay her way
yeah pay for her to tell her him in the
Bahamas but like he doesn't pay for [ __ ]
ya know I feel like the trips are too
extravagant like there's no bill it's
not like a regular hotel it's like it's
all just paid for do you like that's why
rich people travel you don't just get a
hotel room like you get a home yeah you
don't get like a bill it just charges
your platinum Amex right well I totally
agree okay wait so they have the
conversation they get absolutely nothing
resolved so I'm just being very upfront
Carol doesn't want to hear anything
reasonable or rational rational rational
rational I think everything I count like
it's just hard to say I don't like any
more I don't wanna be your friend
anymore for whatever reason whatever
threat you posed to me like so I'm just
gonna keep having this talk with you
about why we're not friends hoping that
you'll say something that will give me a
reason not orderly
to what people are saying people who are
Carol defenders is like Carol and
Bethany had this friendship for so many
years that was only about Bethany and I
hear that statement and I don't disagree
I just I don't see the problem in it
like and I know this is like a [ __ ] up
thing to say but like they're just
people in this world who the world
really like revolves around that like
well you know like their world revolves
around them like and Bethany is just the
center of this universe in New York and
that's like I understand what I
understand but there are people and I
know this is like [ __ ] up cuz like
we're all equal but like there are
people who are meant to be like
someone's friend and then there are
people who are meant to be like a person
with friends do you know what I mean
yeah and that thing is just one of those
people who's too strong too powerful to
like see you know the catch and talk
about Adam like [ __ ] and Carroll has
always projected this like sidekick
mentality and she just decided to change
it and didn't tell anyone and that's
what Bethany can't say is like we had
this dynamic that worked for both of us
and you never once complained about it
you enjoyed all the fruits of being my
sidekick and now you've decided you
don't want to be a sidekick and I can't
say that to you
that's what's not being said what's not
being said it's like I've been your
sidekick forever and I was okay with it
but now I'm not right and it's not geez
Carol wait sorry Carol is so adamant
about and she's posting about our
Instagram and she said it in her side
commentaries she said she's so adamant
to say that she hasn't changed but the
cause of this fight is that she has
changed it's not a bad thing she doesn't
want to be a sidekick anymore just admit
it
right and like if you don't want to be a
size K any more
want to be like you need to be a power
player that is trying you need to change
if you're gonna change the juice your
sidekick mentality you have to change
your sidekick lifestyle and I think if
she came to Bethany with like real like
she was running a charity with problems
she had a business she was starting a
jean line but it wasn't that Bethany
wasn't interested it was that Carroll
had nothing great right so if Carol
started bringing some Bethenny would
have been there for her but you say you
don't just get to be main kick yeah you
have nothing main about you know and
I've been trying to find a coherent way
to say this but I haven't been able like
there are just people in this world
whose personalities whose lives are
bigger and they require more but some
people gravitate towards them
opportunities gravitate towards them and
they just they just have [ __ ] going on
totally and like that's not a reasonable
thing to say like in a reunion now so
Bethenny and then he can't say about
herself right I'm happy to say about her
yeah and like I took if Carroll would
just admit that she's changed but Carol
isn't saying it's like I was okay being
your little buddy but now I've decided I
want to be in charge and just admit that
like and that's what everyone around
them is saying is that Carol like found
her voice and that's fine good for you
just say it like stop acting like you
don't know what happened you know full
and well what happened you don't want to
be someone's [ __ ] anymore very
understandable but go she's going about
it in the worst possible way and she's
coming off me and now that I think about
it that's kind of what happened with
Bethenny and Jill Bethenny with Carol
Bethenny was the sidekick and I don't
think she decided I don't want to be a
sidekick anymore her [ __ ] circle on
main kick roles and then Jill was like I
don't want to Maine I don't want to be
why did she underdog and then when
Bethenny's to stop started to rise she
was threatened by it Carol just decided
to rise her own stock similar right so
like that's super interesting and that's
what they were saying in the car ride
home from dinner which was something
that all definites friendships are in
conflict and like they were about
revolve around just like tension and I'm
such a mean I said that speaks more to
the people that are involved in it than
her because it's like she is so sick
like I think it's hard to be friends
with her without being threatened by her
because they're also all in the same
industry of reality to me and it's like
I'm just you know in our business and
you could have done the same thing but
did it right they're all sort of like
Petitte --iv it's very competitive in
Bethenny's the winner so it's hard being
friends with the winner when you're the
loser
no and everyone turning on Bethenny is
like they look so stupid because their
rage and their rage with their problem
with Bethenny it's just fueled by
jealousy yeah and that's what no one can
say like all these [ __ ] are jealous
like Ramona and her skin care line
Ramona under Pinot Grigio will never
make enough money as like one Skinnygirl
products like and they hate Bethenny and
I'm sure Bethenny's used to people
coming fair but like now when one person
did it they all decided to do it
together because they think there's
power in numbers but just because
there's more of you that doesn't mean
you're you're right and it was Carole
the person who became her friend when
she was already at the top knowing full
well what the job required
I understand how Ramona will always
resent Bethenny they started out there
Ramona was here Bethenny was here and
now Bethenny is here totally Carole came
into this friendship knowing full well
who Bethenny was right away wired so you
don't just get to turn like nothing
changed
that's an amazing point I hope someone
shows this episode to Bethenny I'm sure
one of her assistants watched the toes
well so I have just been like I've
really been thinking about it a lot and
like I really feel like Bethenny but
some toasters have said they met
Bethenny and she was like kind of rude
and like I totally like understand her
being rude like I can't slay don't know
why I'm so blindly defending her but
like she is just a different species
like and I can understand people just
like wanting stuff from her and like not
wanting to take on new friends who like
are thirsty but like when she got that
surgery and she's like really she said
she's like I really don't have anyone I
don't have any family I don't have like
a lot of real friends like it's like
super sad and like we were talking about
like Demi like I really feel like I
would be perfect for her Bethenny
because I believe would understand my
position it's like I'm fun and like I
don't need you I don't even like to talk
about myself like when I went out to
dinner my friends like you guys talk I
just want to listen like my life is not
interesting like talking about it makes
me depressing I wanna hear about your
problems no let me help you like I
really feel like I would be a good
friend like I'm fun we have similar like
social circles I can go to the Hamptons
like have a good time drink wine and
then we could also just like chill I'm
douchebag dinner and like have just like
a family home down experience right I
really feel like she needs like that
Kardashian ashtray like sisterly vibe
because she doesn't have family that
she's close with and I just wanted to
put it out into the universe that I
nominate myself to be friends with
Bethenny because I really feel like I'd
be good for it and I think that like
she's it's like she's a Kardashian it's
like she has everything except that
family Union and that's why she
struggles so much
she's trying to stay on the ground right
it's like it's so hard to believe the
Kardashians but they don't care cuz they
have each other right she doesn't know
it must be hard to be alone at the top a
hundred percent so let's not even alone
but like there's people at the bottom
like trying to bring down the Jason
Carroll everyone never trusted hmm um
okay so bad that I some tea that I did
here like insider scoop as to why Carol
it's not clear if she left or was fired
they usually don't say but apparently
Carol really comes for Andy at the
reunion how is that possible this is
dumb like you know like what don't
things gonna happen I'm not part of the
reason why she either like wasn't asked
back or whatever I don't think she
wasn't asked back though because it's
like this is what everyone's talking
about you don't go for me the most
talked about to non-existent that's true
unless you're like Caprice from Layton
London but I think people would have
been interested to see the way it plays
out next season so I don't think I think
she did leave on her own accord but I
think it's because she embarrassed
herself yeah so then they go to dinner
and they get to this dinner that is just
so awkward and honestly what's so funny
is going the editing was great going
back and forth between the fights and
then literally like you see Sonia and
Tinsley kiss on the lips like and then
have it is rare that like it was just
like so evident of like how much was
going on Zak was watching with me and
like up looking up and down from his
phone and wasn't till the very end he's
like they're all at the same table yeah
so like it's just so stupid because like
Bethenny has been trying to get through
to Carol and Carol's been just like not
interested like she's too cool to above
it and then Carol decides like oh us our
dynamics ruining the trip let's talk it
out like Bethany's been trying to talk
to you for weeks like she you guys went
out to lunch if she's been reaching out
so now you decide it's too much for you
and the group it's affecting Tinsley so
now Kelly's terrible trip this will go
down as one of the worst hazards in
history and not because of the fighting
I know but and that's on Tinsley yeah
totally and they just talk about nothing
about nothing and what really pissed me
off about Carol is she started to say
like Bethenny said you're too cool for
me you'll just find that into me and
then Carol goes like when she was like
we don't have a relationship anymore
about buying cow goes maybe they're just
not that into me like right Bethenny
just said that you can't sell her line
totally they were just saying nothing
and I was like I wanted them to like go
at it but like they were saying nothing
because there's nothing because the
thing that needs to be said is socially
unacceptable right Bethenny is just like
a more interesting person and requires
more time in the friendship and Carol
decided she does want to be psychic
anymore like you can't Carol Carol
refuses to admit that she was a sidekick
which is why she doesn't want to say
that she's changed into not a side and
it's because Carol got a taste of the
main chick life with Tinsley because now
she has her own sidekick and Tinsley is
perfect sidekick perfect in a couple of
years though when she shakes off gets
one in turn father's okay totally
um and then Dorinda and LuAnn and I've
had a problem with Dorinda ever since
Miami and I'm so glad that all the
ladies are here to witness it because
like what's not being said by anyone
it's like and I know
Luann's in rehab so all this is
completely ironic and like not even
worth mentioning but like just between
the two of them like I don't even ever
seen LuAnn act nearly as out of control
as I've seen Dorinda and that's why
before she went to rehab for the second
time I was like is she an alcoholic like
does she need to stop drinking and I
guess what she does is off-camera and
it's like I don't see it but like if
you're doing if you can't even stop
doing it on camera like I would if I was
on the show like I would be here my
absolute best and then like be a
psychopath off-camera
durand I can't even stop drinking long
enough while they're filming just one
night like to not be embarrassing or
like she can't even stop drinking after
a terrible fight about drinking right
she's a home having rose and a cigarette
it's like and we said like after the
Miami thing that what she did was
unforgivable and like she Bethenny was
way too kind on her mom and I'm just
glad way to forgive it I'm glad that
it's bubbling up back to the top because
it's like this underlying storyline
where she just like gets trans - it's
like people love her so they forgive her
and it's kind of it's becoming
unforgivable no no and I never even
loved her enough to forgive her but all
of this is like I'm like annoyed because
I feel so strongly about the Duran Duran
fight but all of it is like for naught
because there's nothing because Luann's
back in rehab and they look like they
were right in making fun of her but I
just want to say I'm only see things in
that moment in that moment I like LuAnn
was legit and legit legit and I know
them and they self building should feel
me she probably didn't have as much
accountability is like she can't drink
on camera because if a judge sees it
like she's out so she didn't have that
like security and she definitely fell
back into her old ways but like in that
moment she was sober and she was really
doing a good job and she was trying
really hard and like these girls have no
I was back to no empathy like they what
Dorinda was saying is like she Luann's
gonna tell me you know like cut back
when you just got arrested and like I
kind of get that but like first of all
that's just such an insensitive thing to
say when someone's trying so hard to be
a better person it's like knowing these
girls like don't care they have no
sympathy for anyone and it's like the
way they talk about LuAnn like and and
her recovery is like so condescending
when it's like and I know it sounds
stupid because now she's that can rehab
but like in that moment she was sober
and she was working really hard and she
did really care so like it's it's a
stupid argument because I'm wrong
because here's the thing
yeah and now keeping the information we
have now we lose that argument but I
think we won the more important one
which is Bethany in Carroll because Kara
left proving us right yeah the other
thing I'll say is that Jordan was so
wrong in everything that she did last
night but then Carroll says her are you
just feeling resentful because you've
been with you've gone through everything
with when she had the winds back when
she married Tom she she'd about LuAnn
she supported her through everything and
I feel like maybe now during this
feeling like you never acknowledged how
good of a friend I am ferret with me
which if she but then journey was like
no that's not the case but if she said
yeah she doesn't acknowledge her there
no care okay for like a good argument
and she throws it away yeah I would
totally see that because she really now
everyone loves him and she's so sober
she's so great but they don't forget
about I am except right but like
everyone was so mean to Luanne before
except Dorinda so now that you're
Luann's the toast of the ground like
Dorinda she doesn't treat you any
differently which she should but does
not even upset about that right no no
totally
and it's the same thing we always say
it's like it's not even what you say
it's how you say it so if that was the
case during the does have like a
legitimate gripe with LuAnn just like
she never got proper things for being
such a good friend
fair the way she went about it she she's
wrong and she'll and she didn't if you
had it a good point in the beginning the
way you say something affects the whole
argument and she lost and she could
never be right again and even though she
had a good point it's completely
irrelevant because what she said about
her having a mock chat about her being a
felon about her being a convict breaking
the glass like you're done you lose
right you're wrong and I think she'd
wake up with a big pit but it doesn't
look like she doesn't look like she does
whereas she usually doesn't by the end
of the night
starting to feel like okay Luanne should
forgive during it seems as though she's
sorry but it looks like at brunch
tomorrow the next day Britney's been
doubling down with southern charm it's
like when people do things drunk at
night you think Ashley's gonna wake up
after that night with Katherine and be
like so ashamed to have a pit and like
not want to leave the woods you'll be so
sorry to the point that Katherine will
feel bad for her um and I I assumed that
was gonna happen with Joran because
sometimes when you're like with drunk
people and like you're fighting like
there's literally no point in keep
talking about it because you're never
gonna resolve it until this person's
sober and I've had that with other
people and I've been that person like
you're just so irrational
so talking and that's why the way and
was like not gonna talk about it anymore
I'm going to sleep because you know that
in the morning when you wake up like the
logic is that it doesn't look like that
happens No and that brunch looks wild
and then Carol starts going after
Bethany right and Bethany was defending
LuAnn but it's like wait sorry someone
said oh my god Andy knows about the
toast look in the toasters all right
where do I look
hang on where do I look I'm gonna search
Andy you guys fun fact Andy Cohen has
confirmed he knows of the toast had the
premium experience of gonna watch up
inside last night my sister and I met
Andy after and I told him I loved Aaron
and then I'm a toaster he told me he had
just heard of the morning toast earlier
that day I'm dead you guys someone needs
to show them this episode because our
analysis is so good we need this
profession the morning shows meets yeah
Bravo oh my god wait um shucks I have
like a pit I don't know why you know you
get like a good pinch yeah yeah just
because it's like the anxiety yeah yeah
like what does he think about you know I
feel like I wonder what he saw oh my god
I'm sad I hope it was good what we good
yesterday I was hungover no yesterday
was so fun
was it o-o DG I think that's what he saw
oh my god that's so dope girl on the
sides that would be so crazy
Wow I'm sweating now maybe I was signing
before no I'm sweating too okay
all right let's finish up the episode so
the the meal is relatively useless LuAnn
goes home good for her for knowing
that's how you know she's sober she
knows when it's time to go and like not
make it worse he knows when to hold him
and when to folder and then Ramona was
actually coming to Luann's defense which
Ramona's very rarely on the right side
of history so I was like shocked by it
and then she totally she took one step
back and 30 steps backward one steps
forward and three steps backwards on
watch happens live um yeah cuz all in
all this season Ramona has been like
pretty sympathetic
looks amazing not getting in
the weeds not really saving thanks to
people that are unforgivable and I've
really been enjoying her but then she's
like I surrender
I think I think what happened what
happened to Lisa Rinna is that she
changed uh-huh
she had such a good experience on the
show the reunion was a breeze for her
that she's never gonna go back to the
way she is I think Ramona changed she
had such a good experience on the show
the room is a breeze for her and she
misses the drama yeah totally she's
insatiable she's insatiable so I think
she's going back to her Ramona coaster
ways and honestly I'm here for it that's
singer singer you can't put out that Bo
totally um so they they leave the
restaurant they all eventually call
outside Sonja cause Ramona's singer was
trying on the Hat she's like singer just
like you know I hate singer but you know
so I was gonna guess her finger and
Ramona are two different people the
singer it's like her alter ego yeah
total and she's like evil Mara and she's
like being just like drunken fun
Bethenny gets in the car crying did you
see they cut to it for one second she's
opening the car door and she's like I
start the cross yeah I thought maybe the
girls we're gonna get in the car
you know because Ramona walked up to the
car as Bethenny was pulling away Josh
yeah please
and then they all get into the car and
like I thought that conversation in the
car was so telling of how evil that
group of girls is well you know what I
think it is I think those car scenes
like don't really make it to camera
because it's like it's not it's not the
door doesn't subtitle know who's saying
what and so you can kind of just like
say what you're really thinking whereas
at a dinner table you're you know you're
being filmed and I think that was really
like the truth that came out in that car
yes I that I hear you Harrell's in the
back backseat when I'm in the back
backseat I'm just saying no one's not
and I'm just thinking no one's gonna
baby person friends II can hear you I'm
not thinking about what is the more
Nieto is gonna say about this or anybody
right right so I just think like the
what they were saying I was like these
girls are evil they're really evil like
saying like who is Lemann to to cast any
dispersions on anyone about drinking
when she just got out of rehab which
would be a good argument for an evil
person but like a nice person would be
like you know what me like she's been
through a lot maybe she doesn't want to
rent it end up in Cartagena jail right
but maybe because shot the thought of
LuAnn maybe having like a good intention
is like lost on these girls like they
just have to look at everything for like
this evil standpoint I totally that part
I was so telling I can't explain it they
just like everything they said was just
so negative and so derogatory I'm like
wow these girls are evil
totally it's only war geez then they go
and that's only when turn the cameras
off me - I'm so glad Bethany told LuAnn
about Puerto Rico I can't believe she
never told anyone that's I have a person
she and I didn't even think that she can
tell anyone I just assumed like everyone
knew she don't even know or that like
she's living he didn't tell anyone she
must have not even told her friends who
weren't who don't know during that look
she didn't tell a soul
yeah because she's a good friend Yeah
right exactly
cuz it's mortifying and honestly Bethany
was my black ever we'll see and like
honestly watching it and Bethenny
couldn't even do with justice in in
saying it because you have to see it to
believe it it has to see it to believe
it like these people are rebuilding
Haiti and drew vinda is going in on them
saying that it's like it's it's
unbelievably those kids in a little
Oregon that was so crazy I'm just glad
that all what's done in the dark always
comes to light I'm glad they do not turn
off the cameras when they got back to
the house
I'm glad LuAnn and Bethenny are like a
good friends and by the way I think that
they still are good friends because when
LuAnn decided to go to rehab and not the
reunion Bethenny was the one who
announced it like she confided in Beth I
suppose she normally would to have
Dorinda do it there's just one thing
that I need I need Bethenny to issue in
a major apology for like all the
horrible things that she said that her
I'm sure maybe she'd be like wait you
need to say Bethenny to issue LuAnn I
wouldn't bet they better oh my god in
the past years just like everything
Luann's a loser all this but LuAnn has
said equal that reunion where she was
engaged now not what she was a true that
sad reunion was the most horrible
reunion ever like the way she was saying
that Bethenny is married to him like
dating a married man like rumors like
that catch fire that's sure and she's
still with Dennis and he wasn't married
like it's just so I guess I just always
think about that BerkShares episode
where like Bethenny's calling her a
[ __ ] like and I know that Bethenny
feels terrible about that moment too but
it's just like the cheater brand it's
like I can't forget it no totally but
soda has never done anything to Bethenny
that was equally as bad as that
conversation about the cheater brand
whereas best thing in the land have both
gone below the belt I agree and maybe
they just they don't say anything they
just both walk post what if they could
both apologize or they give up just
ignore it and their face yeah the show
like people who are best friends going
to the Galapagos Islands like Bethenny
Karl can become enemy sworn enemy Carole
and LuAnn go into coffee when LuAnn is
called Carole a pedophile and Bethenny
and LuAnn becoming like relation cycles
yeah when I know this is like this is
literally Beverly Hills like to read or
and Lisa becoming best friends I didn't
know that I needed that Carole LuAnn
Sonia becoming best friends didn't know
I needed it but I don't mean the wind
sewing yeah sorry yeah yeah Co totally
and that's what's so great about this
show you know just bringing people
together so let's just wrap up they get
back to the house I can something about
the fact that any Cohen like knows our
show no I know and someone someone's I
really feel like Bethenny's assistance
definitely are toasters because there
are demo ya know if you work for
Skinnygirl if you're related to
Bethenny's workers to show her like that
these two girls on the morning toasts
are out here in the streets I'm I'm in
comment sections like fighting for
Bethenny know always and every time you
have a guest co-host on like I go to bat
for her and after this week's episode I
feel even strongly and I'm Jim stronger
and I I'm sure when Darren comes back in
to host with me or anyone this isn't
over
so Luanne I mean Bethenny comes about
downstairs from Luann's room which is
like this is the greatest trip ever
and Karen is so drunk she's like yeah it
is like she really felt was and I can't
believe nobody said anything to joinder
about the lipstick because it was all
over her face at the restaurant yeah and
then Carole sitting there being like
what do you mean what's on her face like
a blind person have to be honest I'm the
type of person I it's not because I'm
malicious I'm just too awkward if
someone is something in their teeth like
it pains me to say something to see it
later and be like oh I guess I just got
there right right right
I'd like to live a lie um and that was
nice of Bethenny to like clean cleaner
face off but when the three of them are
sitting there having a conversation for
like a second it was like so awkward
like yeah
the huge elephant in the room right but
I was glad that Bethenny was just
showing up and not just like go in her
room yep done with it because it shows
you know what I talked to Carol we've
decided that we're just not friends and
we're gonna go on the rest of the show
the way that you know two other people
like the way that LuAnn and Carole
interact with each other they're my
friends they'll film together right they
don't hate each other but they certainly
don't like each other fine you don't
need to be friends with everyone know
sometimes a conversation just being like
I think we're too different now and like
we're probably just like aren't good
friends like is fine and that's a good
thing in housewives there has to be a
reason for everything no sometimes two
people are just not made to be friends
anymore you grow up you change you
whatever like and that's fine but why is
nobody saying that all of this could
have been avoided if like if people
Carol had just been upfront no and all
the girls are being like Carol and
Bethenny have to talk they have to talk
everyone's loves talking about Carolyn
Bethenny and one of them's just be like
why do they have to talk why do they
have to be friends we're all gonna be
okay if they're not and then after the
episode while trevin's live was on and
the guests were
Mona singer and Megan McCain and I was
literally shook to my core that Megan
McCain was in the first seat because in
Andy's book she always talks about her
like that's literally the one thing
housewives complain about like when they
come in the show and he says there's no
difference and there is no difference
it's like a prestige thing and he says
he swears it really doesn't mean
anything and I don't think that it does
but like to Ramona like it means
everything and now Ramona's not sitting
next to Andy at the Reunion and she's
not sitting that come on and that's why
she's gonna go back to being singer
singer necks and I think literally last
night she saw she was in the second seat
she was like wow I'm really not making a
splash I'm gonna say some crazy [ __ ] on
this show because I need to be back in
the first seat I was so impressed by
Meghan McCain last me too
first of all talking about the
housewives on the right side pissed
about every time I don't watch the view
so I don't know I just know that it's
like the scariest show on television it
is the scariest show on television and
everything that like every question that
was asked of her and like all the time
very diplomatic are so tight like toxic
you say one wrong thing and you are done
you'll never guess and she just handled
herself so well she looks great too and
she looks so great she is like she
watches the toes so like I love her yeah
she's a big runs fan so what it was
super weird because like they weren't
being combative but like they were both
on opposite sides and it made me rethink
everything because the way Ramona was
blindly defending Carole in every
instance was almost like I have to be
missing something
do you know what I mean what am I
missing what happened that I didn't see
wonderful I think reunion happened right
and that's like a lots gonna come out
and Ramona's saying that Bethenny made
up the tag right so when they were they
were just recapping with certain things
and they were talking about the red
scarf thing and Ramona says that those
text messages from the red scarf thigh
are were lies some of them were from
like six months ago and that Bethenny
was like bringing them up now because it
was a name for her they met on the
league like I well now like a year ago
like that is just first of all that
thing is a lot of things you could say
what you want to have a thing she's
definitely super harsh she can be kind
of mean she can be a little
self-involved she's not a liar
like she and she's not delusional right
like she would never say a text message
is from someone if it's not from them or
that she got it yesterday and it was
from six months no like that's something
Ramona would do it she would it she
wouldn't use a text message to her
advantage and change some of the facts
that's something LuAnn would definitely
do that jaronda yes that it's not
something definitely was the thing I
don't give a [ __ ] about the text
messages I don't care if they never
exists I I know what I saw on camera him
going for her that's
I need to see that's all I need to know
these Testament text messages you can
shove them up your ass
they don't even mean anything to me I
went on Twitter last night after watched
repins live because I wanted to see what
everyone was what all the housewives
were tweeting about after the episode
and after watch rap is live and nobody
tweeted a single thing like Carlton
tweet and she usually does like
shadiness Bethany geo nobody the reunion
must have been bad yeah I'm excited me
too very exciting it was just it was it
was too much it was it last night I
couldn't sleep
I went bed at 1:00 I was up for 30
minutes just like thinking about how
involved I felt in this episode we just
haven't had like a housewives moment
like this has really taken the country
by storm and honestly we needed it
because last season a brownie was meth
there's been a lot of met OC is kind of
met right now because it just started up
again and I think this is what the Bravo
community needed yep to feel so strongly
about something one way or the other and
I feel like we are all really
invigorated especially about your house
days of New York which isn't an iconic
franchise iconic franchise thank you
Andy Cohen for doing the Lord's work I
literally feel exhausted I'm feel like I
got everything off my chest that I
really felt and I feel good yeah I feel
like we're at Deadhorse mode
yeah we're beating a dead horse let's
end the show thank you guys so much for
watching there is no show tomorrow as
I'm in Phoenix and it's summer Friday
and I'm taking a personal day how nice
for you
but we are recording patreon episode
tonight with Tina patreon.com slash the
morning toast so if you're looking for
some content tomorrow to talk about with
Sally at the water cooler hmm go to the
patreon there's a ton of [ __ ] there we
will see you guys on Monday have an
amazing weekend
you